when you sit down or anybody sits down
to write an album it's not gonna work
unless you have something to say what
did you have to say and has that changed
now since we're all going through this
yeah I mean for me on this album what I
had to say was it was a very self you
know I'm on my music it's about me and
it's about my life and it's it's a diary
entry and it was this how with me was an
album to say I think for the first time
I I started to really realize what love
was I went through a relationship and
and it showed me how much I didn't it
wasn't being nice to myself and this
album was really a celebration of me and
all my imperfections and and also a
coming home I guess in terms of me
really starting to cook words to how I
felt in terms of my queerness and my
gender and and all these things and also
it was now album where I just wasn't
listening to anyone around me and I was
just doing what I wanted to do I think
that's still going to be the message but
I do I just want to be super sensitive
with wording with artwork with with the
music so that it's it's sensitive to the
times because this yet my fans would
have lost people during this time you
know and I don't want to be bringing out
depressing songs cool to die for right
right and and and with that there is so
much uncertainty that's the thing that
everybody in the world right now is
going through as we don't know what's
happening so are you even at a point of
where you can sort of figure out when
the album is going to come out or is
just all life on hope now and we have a
rough idea but it's nothing set it's set
in stone until until we we know what's
going to happen what's going to go on
and I mean I feel very lucky because I'm
I'm you know I'm not on you I and I and
I've got a lot of music and I'm and I'm
and I can wait you know yeah yeah I'm in
a position where I can wait until it's
the right time and and that's what I'll
do you know you just got a gauge
when it's the win this is going to start
because I don't know none of us know
with with Demi Lovato oftentimes two
beautiful voices sometimes don't work
together you know this this this does
when did you know that you guys had that
thing where it just sounded perfect I'd
you know why it's weird but like I
overdid there would work because I've
been I think mainly because then he's
been I'm a student of Demi's voice
rightly like growing up growing up
listening to her music and singing to
her music and and trying to sing like
Demi Lovato
as you know I'd be training for this by
the I absolutely adore her and I just
everything she stands for as well as her
incredible talent everything she stands
for as a human being is is what I
believe in and yeah I just I just adore
her so I'm so happy it's worked and I
hope this isn't the last time we came
together we collectively you know the
world was rooting for Demi Lovato and
there was a moment where we thought we
may not get anything new from Demi
Lovato and so to hear this where did
this happen in that process did you ask
her if she was ready to sort of put
something down with you that was going
to be you know at this level like were
you sensitive to sort of her situation
going into going into this collaboration
well completely very very sensitive I'm
um you know I I I had only been you know
I've been in contact with Demi for the
last few years and and you know more
before music or anything you know I
wanted to you know reach out to her as a
friend you know and that's what that's
what I did and we were in contact and
then she was I was basically working
with a group of guys from the Max Martin
who are incredible and serve and has a
relationship with Demi and had written
with Demi before and they've I think
they wrote I think they were cool for
the summer or I'm no confident I think
they wrote that song together so um he
reached out to Damian was just like ie
are you down to come to the studio and
she came to this you
and she just seemed as an amazing place
I'm she she's the strongest person I've
ever known and what she's gone through
is it's something that I I can't imagine
you know how she's felt at times and and
just to what but I have struggled myself
with loads of mental health issues and
watching her journey and her her
composure through all of this it's just
so inspiring to me it really is the
intent behind I'm ready
there's a difference between I'm ready
to love and I'm ready for someone to
love me mmm yeah yeah talk me through
that talk me through that difference
because because you to say ready for
someone to love me implies that you have
now come to some sort of peace where you
are now ready to accept as opposed to
give right yeah I mean that this is what
with this album I I don't know why it is
taking me maybe it maybe it does take
this long to figure this these things oh
I don't know I'm still trying to figure
it out though
when it comes to love I always thought
love was something that just you're
given like if I gave thank you and and
and suddenly you're in a Hollywood movie
but I I realized through having one of
my first relationships a few years back
that love is something that you you
water and you look after and you nurture
it's not something that you take or
something that you give away and I've
learned that and I have done you know I
the last he has been really tough for me
and I started therapy and and I just
really got into what was going on and
why I was feeling someone lovable was a
person and I did a lot of inside work
and that was hard and then I got to this
place was like okay I'm now ready to
show someone my most vulnerable side and
that that's what it is it's love I think
is about someone taking the jump you
know and falling without certainty that
they're going to be okay you know
and that's why and to make the track
where were the that is the message and
it's that deep and you had to go sort of
into your own head
but to make it a danceable song as
opposed to something that is slow that
we may want to cry to to make it a
danceable song why was that decision me
because I think it's a brilliant
decision but because is it because it is
so positive is that where your head was
is that why yeah no so do you know what
I buy when I talk about it and in these
interviews I sound deep but it wasn't a
deep faith I believe we we were just
sitting in the studio and I started
singing that melody and then it was it's
a for me it's a cheesy melody you know
just like yeah but that's exactly how
I'm feeling right now I don't really
want to say any much more than what I've
just said so let's just build the song
and we built the song and and for me the
music video as well was just such the
music video is is part and part with the
song because and I just more didn't want
to take myself too seriously you know
right and that's that's what I've done
with the song and that's why I think
releasing it now it feels okay because
this sounds just about smiling and and
reaching for the stars and playing you
know playing around and having fun